an Australian teenager has filed a
lawsuit against several publications
thanks to this image the lawsuit claims
that ever since this photos publication
a plaintiff has been relentlessly memed
because of his luxuriant haircut
that's all business in the front party
in the back Staten Island garbage man on
top and medieval monk with leukemia on
the sides the lawsuit specifically
mentions this image of someone trying to
pin the mullet on the donkey I have to
say this one's my favorite this worry
looks like this this looks like he's
about the DJ a dubstep rave at the Alamo
but one of the defendants fired back
quote by reason of his mullet hairstyle
the plaintiff has justifiably exposed
himself to ridicule and quote the
plaintiff is a ridiculous person
either way sustained
Udall allow it either way this landmark
case could open the floodgates for other
memes to sue so comedians what's another
internet celebrity who might seek legal
recourse and what are they suing for
Nikko that cop is suing from what those
two awful girls did to him yeah all
right points Colton the Chocolate Rain
guy is suing the weather channel for
classifying chocolate rain as climate
change all right cool one grumpy cat is
gonna sue for defamation because that
cat is not grumpy she's just got resting
bitchface yeah